あなたの人生で
一番大切なのは何
私は大学4年の時
究極の自給自足の生活を対応するため
オーストラリアのトップ
なぜそんなことをしたらいいか
私実は大学前茗渓したかったんです
ここで優勢
タイムでいなくて今日炭を出されることでした
第五洋への最後に行かせました
してありがとうございます
なので大学4年ん
人と違ってほどとそのテーマの時で英語を話せない曲だった
日本人が1人だけの
飛び込みました
究極の自給自足の生活が始まりました
みなさんどんな生活を想像しますか
電気やガスはありません
誘導もありませんでした
ペットもありません
おっ
寝袋で寝ます
さて皆さんここでクイズです
はホヤアラームがありませんでした
なので朝起こされる方法がとてもユニークでした
なんだと思いますか
おら階です
本当の話です
50メートル離れたところからチームリーダーがほぉー
とほら貝を吹きます
そして起きるという生活でした
移動もありませんでした
水の調達の方法もユニークでした
バケツを道端に置いとくんです
と雨水を食べます
お風呂の方法もとてもユニークでした
だめだ雨水を温めてできようになったらこの黒のタンクに移します
そして
プロのタンクに移し替えたら緑のロープを引っ張り
あって木の上の方の高さまで行ったらこの黒タンクのスターの部分に穴を開けます
タワーの完成です
とても原始的ですよね
前に溶け込んで生活をしていたので
野生の動物たちでも随分仲良くなりました
こちらは野生のカンガルーです
私たちになついていて親の扉をカリカリと
ドックしてくる姿です
女生活でした
とっても楽しそうに見えると思いますがとてつもなく不便でした
そしてさらに私はある重要なアイテムを持ってませんでした
英語です
幻想でも何でもなく私は英語が話せません
何も便利な道具がなくて不便ただにコミュニケーションも満足に取れない状況でした
トレスフルな生活
しかし不思議なことに私はとっても幸せでした
何も持ってないように見えてある一つのものを持っていました
心のつながりです
ゲームメンバーはとってもあったかい人たちでした家族みたいな関係でした
彼らは英語をゆっくりゆっくり話私にこれらのような言葉をかけてくれました
あなたの笑顔キス的な
一生仲間でいいような
俺らの体験から私の幸せは心のつながりにあると学びました
フェリーなアイテムがなくたっていい飛ばされなくたっていい
心の繋がりさえあれば私はこんなに幸せなんだとの体験から学びました
ここから日本に帰国しました
社会人になって大手の広告代理店に入社しました
朝8時から夜中まで働く生活をしてました
オーストラリアで感じたことをすっかり忘れてしまっていました
行き帰りは基本満員電車でした
私は電車の中でスマホを開いて facebook を見てました
フェイスブックを見て今日はこの人の誕生日ですと通知が出ます
そしてあこの子の誕生日か忘れてたなぁと思いながらおめでとうどボールに書き込んで
ました
そしてまた別の投稿を見るということをしてました
家族の誕生日も同じでした
私は母の誕生日にラインを開いておめでとうのスタンプを送ってました
そしてまた別のラインをしてました
さて私が何気なくを行っていた行動
私はある違和感を感じ始めました皆さんはどうですか
俺はあまりにもあっけないということです
フェイスブックを開いて通知を見ておめでとうの小文字を置く
その間約30秒です
まじ仕事は朝8時から夜24時まで16時間費やすんです
その差なんと1920バイ
大切な人の大切な記念日は仕事の1920分の1なんです
私て私はそれで幸せなんでしょうか
答えは no でした
私は今の自分の生き方は間違っているなぁと感じました
そして何を大切にしたいだろうと考えた時にやっと思い出しました
悪露のつながりだと
をから私は生き方を変えることを決意しました
この繋がりを大切にした生き方にです
そして私がどうやって生活を支えたか
具体的に2つのことを見直しましたまず一つ
のとしてのあり方です
先ほど違和感を感じていたおめでとうの伝え方をまず変えました
私はできるだけ直接おめでとうを伝える
難しくても電話で伝えるように変えました
楽にギフトやお手紙お花贈ったりもしました
そしてそういうことをしているうちに
で頭とかありがとうの気持ちっておっ
農的に伝えたいなと思うようになりました
例えば私半年前に息子を出産したんです
その時に分かりました
なんて命がけだと
私が今ここに立っていること奇跡なんだとわかりました
そして両親に感謝するようになりました
でくれてありがとうと伝えました
そこに対しても同様です
をが生まれてきてくれたことそれは奇跡です
あなたがいて私がどれだけ幸せか
こういうことを深く考えるようになりました
生まれてきてくれてありがとう等倍判ペットの中で伝えるようになりました
ついて渡した私は変えたことの二つ目で仕事の内容です
私は大切にしたい心のつながりこれを他の人にも提起をしたいと考えるようになりまし
た
そして私は起業しこのようなサービスを立ち上げました
結婚式送ろうというサービ
現在日本の婚姻件数は年間約60万組です
でも結婚式あげてるのってそのうちどれぐらいから皆さんご存知ですか
約半数だんです
意外と少ないんです
残りの半数の方は結婚式を挙げずに終わっています
そしてその後夫婦の周りの方はあの子の結婚していなかったなーって思ったり
ウェディングドレスをつけてあげたいなーって思ったりしています
という方に向けたサービスです
なので周りの方が結婚式自体を企画して新郎新婦にプレゼントするというものです
今日は動画をご用意しました
こちらはある女性がご両親に送ったものです
それでは動画をご覧下さい
家が昔
ウェディングドレス着たかったなーってボソッとなんかそれが
自分の中で何か引っかかって
[音楽]
もしこれがなかったら
ちょっとなかったんじゃないかぞん
娘の花嫁姿を見る前に
花ゆめ姿をその後なってるよな
[音楽]
hey
私後ろ
[音楽]
を始まる前からもなんだね
たあくんと仲がいいので
憧れの夫婦といいカーン
すごいなぁと思いながら
f から思ってたのはこういう風
たいなっていうのがいい
と思っています
[音楽]
ねえ
ジャッジドレッドだって
それだけの闘争を打った時は
ダメだなった俊英
どんなに向かった感じでもええ
が届かないん
越えられない私にとった感がに
れていません
[音楽]
我がでしたか
までもこんなシーンで利用されています
浦和お孫さんがおじいちゃんおばあちゃんに送った結婚式です
ルー12際の花読む
入籍して入籍した途端戦争が始まったため結婚式を挙げられなかったそうです
こちらは大の仲良しの親友に結婚式を送った様子です
とても喜ばれています
こちらはご両親の結婚50周年のピン今式の記念に開けていなかった結婚式は
プレゼントしたものです
ありもこんなサービスを行っています
履正社進展を送ろう
秋ほどは結婚式という空間自体をプレゼントするものでしたがこちらは
車インテントいう空間自体をプレゼントした
親展って普通プロのカメラマンが行うものですがこちらは一般の人が企画して
大切な人に贈るというものです
例えばこちらは依頼主の20代の女性です
両親に育ててくれてありがとうという気持ちを伝えるために
自分が生まれたときからの写真を掲示し一つ一つに両親に宛てたメッセージを添えまし
た
あプライズで呼び出されたご両親は何か進展が贈られなんて思ってなかったのでも感動
されてました
声を上げるほどないっ
いかがでしたか
ここまでのプレゼンで皆さん何か役に立つものはあったでしょうか
足ここからが本日最も皆さんにお伝えしたいことです
ここまでのプレゼンただのサクセスストーリーです
で見れば自慢ぱなしみたいなものです
橋私はこういうプレゼンが大嫌いです
なぜなら引いていても自分にはうまくいかないような真似できないような感覚になった
からです
私は生き方を変えるって決意してからいろんな人のプレゼンを見たりいろんな本を読ん
だりしました
足どれもうまくいきませんでした
まずなろ
いっぱいが共有されてないんです
うまくいったことしかお知らせされてないんです
なのでなんとなく自分には出来なさそうに感じていました
なので今日は私の失敗も含めてお話ししたいと思います
私は
の生き方を変えると決意してからをするまで
約2年かかりました
2年もです
2年間何してたと思いますか
何もしてなかったんです
正確に言うと
女何かしようとはしていたんだけれども
実行に移せてなかったんです
それは何故だか
すべてうまくいかせようとしてたんです
私は大切なものを大切にする生き方をしようと決めました
はしそれ以外のもの2番目3番目4番目5番目に大事なものも全部ひっくるめてうまく
いかせようとしたんです
俺が無理だったんです
俺に気付くのに2年もかかってしまいました
そして2年後私はこんな方法に変えました
一番大切なものだけとことん育てていっ
他のものは何とかするという方法です
とっても幼稚な表現なんですが私にはこの表現が一番しっくりきています
具体的に言うと私は心のつながりを大切にするため
2つのものを変えました
同時に
これらのものをいったん手放しました
もなくしました趣味の時間もなく
に働く同士も最初はいませんもちろん安定なんてしてないんです
それがなかなか出来なかったんですはくれ手放せなかったんです
あの時間がありな続いてません
そしてそこからどうなったか
まず
後藤内容に共感して
同志が集まりました
ように仕事をしたいと言ってくれました
同士が集まって労働力が増えるとこの後は売り上げが少しずつ上がってきました
どうですか
バック言ってるように見えるんですが
をでまた
いっぱい押します
得意先が倒産しました
また収入がなくなりましたあとです
そして
また一生懸命働きます
どこからまた売上が上がって本当はオフィスを借りられるようになってきました
そしてまたここで失敗しました
足は詐欺にあってしまいました
適切な判断力がなかったんですこれで数百万失いました
またリスタートです
本当にこんな感じです
これをコツコツコツコツやってきて今はこれだけのものが
単手に入りました
一旦と申し上げたのはまた失うこともあると思っているからです
パシ
何もやってなかった2年と比べたらすごく進んでいます
あと一つ大事なこと
私は真ん中の2つはちゃんとずっと思ってるんです
心の繋がりだけは死守して育てています
なので失敗してもあんまり言いたくないんです
心は幸せなんです
今お伝えしたように一番大切なものだけ
女陰を育てて他のものは何とかする
この方法で私は今までやってきました
最後にみなさんに質問です
人生で一番大切なものは何ですか
私は心のつながりと言いましたがいろんな答えがあると思います
俺をぜひとことん大切にしてください
どうもありがとうございました